[Aplausos]
buenas tardes
uno de los mensajes de la película y
dancing nos dice que todos podemos
aprender los pasos de una coreografía
pero que cada uno tenemos nuestra forma
única particular y diferente a todas de
poderla reproducir yo tomo este tema
para platicar acerca de lo que es la
danza y qué es el baile el baile es la
forma personal que todos perros a
determinado ritmo de acuerdo a lo que
hemos aprendido dentro de nuestra
cultura y con las personas que tenemos
alrededor y la danza es un sistema que
nos permite interactuar con otras
personas de manera
más de forma un poquito más organizada
un investigador de la universidad de
cumbria en reino unido llamado zinc
nickname estudió todas las
características de los bailes de ciertas
ciertas poblaciones en las que se
encuentra que el baile del hombre es
potencialmente fuerte denota liderazgo y
el baile los movimientos en las mujeres
denota potencial reproductivo
y es que todos nacemos con la
posibilidad de podernos mover y lo vamos
adquiriendo
lo vamos desarrollando a través de los
diferentes ritmos que nos van
apareciendo en nuestra vida cuando
estamos escuchando un ritmo como el que
estamos escuchando ahorita con la
batería
no nos damos cuenta empezamos a movernos
llevamos el ritmo con un pie
otros lo llevamos con la mano
si traemos un lápiz hasta hacemos el
signo no sabemos ni por qué nunca hemos
tocado una batería estamos llevando el
ritmo
y ya los que son un poco más atrevidos
pueden empezar a mover los hombros a
sonreír
y hasta cerrarle el ojo a la persona que
está al lado nuestro
si se ve por ahí si podemos ver
ahí está un dibujo que nos encontramos
hace como un año un dibujo que hice yo
cuando tenía como cuatro o cinco años la
verdad es que ni me acuerdo pero me lo
paso mi mamá y está una una bailarina
que se llamaba maría eugenia hay
disculpa en la ortografía verdad
maría eugenia la bailarina con su tutu y
está muy contenta está bailando está
recibiendo los aplausos de la gente yo
creo que es mi alter ego yo no sabía que
me iba a dedicar a la danza porque mi
infancia fue principalmente musical yo
tocaba el piano desde que tenía como
seis años en el instrumento que teníamos
en casa y siempre hubo música mis papás
eran muy aficionados a la música y pues
desde entonces tocaba el piano así es de
que yo quería dedicarme a la música
perdón nada de tiempo después aunque
siempre fue parte muy importante para mí
como espectador me gustaba muchísimo ir
a las funciones de ballet me gustaba
mucho el cascanueces llegué a btr
giselle también y en la televisión podía
ver
de los cisnes cantidad de veces sin
cansarme y la bella durmiente' esos eran
mis ballet favoritos y alguna vez me
escribieron alguna clase de ballet en la
que
no avance
me llamaba más la música y terminaba
otra vez tocando el piano ya en la
preparatoria me anoté a un taller de
jazz y empecé a bailar rap y la música
de los de los 96 y hammer vanilla ice
calo
y transcribir los pasos y me la pasaba
muy bien y investigando un poquito yo
ahora preparando esta charla en en mí en
mi memoria y todo en todo esto tuvo
mucho que ver mi abuela mi abuelita
cuando nos dejaban a mí ya mis primas a
su cargo nos ponía a bailar para
entretenernos nos ponía a crear
coreografías y luego mostrársela hacía
ver que era lo lo nuevo hemos podido
lograr hacer y así pues yo creo que
también mucho tuvo que ver verla a ella
como disfrutaba el baile vernos a
nosotros ella como espectadora y también
bailar a ella le gustaba mucho bailar mi
papá la sacaba a bailar cuando mi
abuelita ponía sus boleros de toña la
negra y bailaba con ya en la sala de mi
casa o en la sala de la suya y para ella
era un momento muy bonito el que pudiera
compartir con alguien
el baile es que tanto le gustaba
inclusive me llegó a platicar que siendo
muy pequeña mientras escuchaba
alguna música clásica en la radio podía
imaginarse a ella misma bailando en un
escenario de un teatro con las luces con
el público y como daba saltos y como
hacía piruetas como una bailarina de
ballet ella decía y yo donde había visto
una bailarina de ballet estamos hablando
de los años 20 30 se en una ciudad
llamada fresnillo zacatecas
en la que no había clases de danza
tampoco había espectáculos como que ya
pudiera ver y pues mucho menos tenía una
televisión yo creo que hay ahí un
elemento en la memoria activa que nos
une a este tipo de actividades
y bueno pues yo profesionalmente en la
danza me inicio mucho más tarde como yo
quería dedicar ir a la música
entró a estudiar una carrera en
educación artística en la que tuve un
acercamiento en una asignatura a la
danza regional a la danza folklórica
siempre me había llamado la atención
pero nunca lo había intentado y ahora
pues tocaba hacer la fuerza en esta
clase redescubro mi afición por por la
danza prácticamente por el baile pues la
tuve siempre
empiezo a tomar a parte clases de danza
regional en la institución donde además
también tomaba algunas clases de música
y por allá en un huequito me encontré un
día una clase de flamenco
y dije de aquí soy
el flamenco es lo que lo que me atrapó
más que ninguna otra danza porque el
flamenco tiene algo para mí que es muy
importante y que es precisamente el que
te deja ser tú mismo
no es que no existan reglas porque
también las hay pero el flamenco tiene
la posibilidad de dejarnos a nosotros
sacar tanto las alegrías como las demás
danzas como las tristezas más profundas
como las penas a través de la danza y
además claro de la condición física y
los brazos y la castañuela y el
zapateado y la la gestual y zación todo
en una sola danza y desde entonces pues
le dedico mi vida mi dinero mi tiempo
mis decisiones de trabajo y todo lo que
tenga que ver con mi vida vivo la danza
así y es que nosotros bailamos desde que
somos muy pequeños es más todavía ni
nacemos y ya estamos en el vientre
materno sincronizando nos con los
latidos del corazón tanto nuestro como
el de nuestra madre
ya brincamos adentro del vientre ya
estamos ahí queriendo movernos y cuando
ya por fin hacemos nos agarra la
abuelita todavía no podemos ni pararnos
y empieza a movernos los brazos ling
ling ling ling ling ling ling un poco no
se la saben porque si no se las cantan
entonces han de ser de otra generación
porque yo he escuchado conmigo con mis
primos y con mis sobrinos y ya no les
digo porque si tengo sobrinos nietos
también entonces
desde entonces inclusive muchos estudios
demuestran que con las secuencias
rítmicas nosotros empezamos siendo niños
a interactuar ya crear lazos afectivos y
lazos sociales con los demás
compañeritos no en el kinder un
investigador llamado edward large de la
universidad de connecticut
él tiene un estudio sobre este tipo de
socialización a través del movimiento
con los niños o sea que sí es objeto de
esto es porque todos lo tenemos ya luego
crecemos y hay algunos que ya no les
gusta bailar pero cuando eran bebés y
niños todos bailaron todos movimos un
poquito la cabeza todos movimos los
hombres
bueno pues también hay un elemento que
es muy importante dentro de la danza y
esto es el espectador como les decía
hace rato yo primero fui espectadora y a
partir de ahí me aficioné a la danza el
espectador la persona que nos ve se
vuelve una parte muy importante para mi
ejecución hay un receptor de lo que yo
quiero decir también esa persona que
está bien y danza crea una conexión
conmigo que le permite tener una
experiencia de catarsis una experiencia
en la que también va a conectarse con el
sentimiento que yo tengo oa la mejor
descubre otro sentimiento o también
descubre pequeña más que no sabe a veces
y el mismo bailarín a mí me ha pasado
que a veces al terminar de ejecutar una
danza llegan y me abrazan qué bonito
esto que existe yo dije ay dios mío aquí
ahora dices pero si eso te hice sentir y
eso te gustó pues gracias no se agradece
porque porque es un momento en el que se
comparte
yo he tratado de analizar qué es lo que
me sucede a mí cuando soy espectadora
sobre todo porque en la parte del
flamenco pues me toca ver a muchísima
gente bailar desde mis alumnas que tengo
desde los 5 hasta los 75 años hasta
compañeros artistas o grandes
personalidades que me encanta conocer y
luego poder disfrutar de su baile y
cuando yo los veo bailar
me sucede una cosa muy extraña empiezo a
ver a la persona su físico pero poco a
poco conforme bailando se va
desvaneciendo el físico ya no veo si la
persona tiene cierta edad si la persona
tiene cierta complexión si la persona es
guapa o no tan agraciada eso pasa a
segundo término y se va quedando solo el
momento y quedando solo la esencia de lo
que está haciendo y para mí eso es el
arte
y bueno antes de concluir me gustaría
compartir con ustedes algunos de los
beneficios de la danza que y del baile
que todas estas investigaciones tienen
por conclusión
como todos aquí somos sangre latina
espero y si no pues pónganse en ese
lugar vamos a empezar a mover un poquito
el pie al ritmo de una rica cumbia y
pónganle en su mente
cualquier acordé de esa cumbia que les
gusta porque a todos nos gusta una
cumbia aunque sea una que
bueno uno de los beneficios de bailar es
que podemos tonificar los músculos
cuando nosotros bailamos
movemos los músculos y esto provoca un
movimiento de una tonificación de los
músculos que están interviniendo
también hay una elasticidad de las
articulaciones y podemos mover los
hombros y ahora les voy a pedir que se
paren todos vamos a pararnos que están
muy serios y todavía nos faltan como
tres pláticas
pega vamos a movernos todos
rompan el hielo como hace ratito ya
llegó más gente
eso
otro de los beneficios de la lanza son
las relaciones sociales cuando
interactuamos con otros al bailar
fortalecemos relación estamos en una
fiesta y salimos amigos de todo el mundo
vamos a arriba los brazos todos
vuelta vuelta vuelta vuelta vuelta
vuelta vamos cadera cadera cadera tal
vez
también bailar nos sirve para
desestresar nos para bajar los niveles
de ansiedad
y para podernos reír a carcajadas vamos
una más arriba arriba arriba eso vuelta
vuelta vuelta vuelta
muevo la cadera arriba los brazos vengan
los hombros bajamos los hombros de gato
hacemos
nos damos un aplauso
muchas gracias
les iba a poner otro mismo pero ya me
está acarreando el reloj el reloj que
hay enfrente bueno ya cuando menos es
expresaron un poquito
no sé si logramos todos los beneficios
antes de irme yo les quiero compartir
qué es lo que él haga este es el baile y
bailamos todos ricos ides estresados
pero les quiero compartir qué es lo que
la danza en grupo en coreografía ha
aportado a mi vida
yo creo que las enseñanzas más grandes
que he tenido primero ha sido que he
conocido a las mejores amistades los
lazos que se hacen en la danza son
inquebrantables
otra cosa es que hemos aprendido a
sobrellevar los errores de los
compañeros de baile para poder salvar el
cuadro escénico y también ponernos en el
lugar del otro porque no es fácil sus
pasos es fácil desde aquí verlo y decir
que por qué no le sale y al momento de
cambiar y hacer sus pasos podemos
entenderlo pero sobre todo porque
siempre hay una oportunidad para hacerlo
mejor muchas gracias
[Aplausos]